tout de suite thomas denys notre
correspondant sergueï lavrov le chef de
la diplomatie russe doit rencontrer le
premier ministre indien narendra modi à
quoi peut-on s'attendre
oui c'est sergueï lavrov bien en fait
tout juste de rencontrer son homologue
indien subramaniam jay shankar la
rencontre s'est déroulée sur une note
amicale et le ministre russe a même fait
l'éloge d'une loyauté mutuelle et en
seine et ancien pardon qui règne entre
les deux pays dont du point de vue russe
et indien c'est une opération à c'est un
succès l'un d'eux va continuer à
autoriser la russie à investir sur le
sous-continent les deux pays vont
discuter les la mise en place d'un
système de paiement en roupies et en
roubles pour contourner les sanctions
internationales et la russie se dit
prête à toute discussion si new delhi
voulait acheter quoi que ce soit venant
de russie je rappelle que l'inde importe
plus de 80% de son armement de russie et
enfin un autre sujet qui a été abordé
c'est la vente par la russie à l'inde
d'un pétrole à prix bradés et c'est
d'ailleurs sur ce dossier que l'inde a
vivement réagi hier aux critiques qui
lui étaient faites de vouloir discuter
ses ressources énergétiques avec
l'approvisionnement énergétique avec la
russie et le ministre des affaires
étrangères a clairement a clairement
souligné une sorte d'hypocrisie et de
double langage de la part des pays
européens qui sont d'accord en fait
l'ailé qui se fournissent
massivement en pétrole et en gaz en
russie et donc nous délivre privilégier
une diplomatie amical et le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe a même évoqué
la possibilité que l'inde joue un rôle
de médiateur entre kiev et moscou l'inde
qui entretient également de bonnes
relations avec les états unis comme en
ue délit peut garder l'équilibré
oui les états les états unis et l'inde
se sont se sont rapprochés ces dernières
années et washington est un allié de
poids pour l'inde notamment dans la
région face à la chine parce que depuis
deux ans l'inde et la chine
entretiennent des relations très tendues
notamment à la frontière indo chinoise
dans l'himalaya est donc évidemment
cette venue de la de lavrov a hérissé
les américains
et notamment ce renforcement des
relations économiques entre la russie et
l'inde même si hier l'un des conseillers
américains qui étaient aussi présents en
inde a dit que les discussions avec new
delhi avait été productive que les états
unis ne tentez n'allait pas essayer de
changer cette amitié entre l'inde et la
russie l'idée était plutôt d'aider le
sous continent à diversifier ses
approvisionnements économique dans la
région même mais quand même un petit
avertissement de la part des américains
attention si la chine venait à vous
créer des problèmes en gros ne vous
attendez pas à ce que la russie viennent
vous était donc en tout cas à quelques
heures de la fin de sa visite ici
sergueï lavrov semble encore semble
avoir encore un message à délivrer il a
annoncé vouloir délivrer un message de
sites personnels anar hendra maudit et
la rencontre est imminente merci
beaucoup thomas denys merci à vous le
sou